لقد راهنت امريكا على الحصان
الخاسر. وما كان عليها ان تستخف
بروسيا. نعم هكذا اعلنتها اوروبا
والروس يقطعون النهر لاقتحام
باخموت وحشود عسكرية اوكرانية
باكثر من سبعين الف جندي يتوجهون
صوب باخموت. فهل نشهد معركة
ملحمية اوكرانيا ايضا تبدأ
باجراءات عسكرية مشددة في الحدود
مع مولدوفة. الف جندي في تدريبات
الفايكنج وعشرات الطائرات والسفن
على حدود روسيا شي جين بينغ يسعى
لتربع الصين على القمة في ولايته
الثالثة فهل تكون كما يقولها
المصريون وبكين تستنسخ احدى اهم
وافخر طائرات امريكا لتصبح سلاحا
بيد التنين الصيني. وواشنطن
تجتمع باثنتي عشرة دولة من اجل
كبح الزعيم الكوري. والسعودية
تغرس شوكة اخرى في حدوق
الامريكان مع الايرانيين وبين
فرنسا وبريطانيا المياه تعود الى
مجاريها. روسيا تذر رمادها على
عيون الاوكران. بعد ان اطلق ابرة
مخدرة بتصريح عابر في الهواء.
طباخ بوتين ومؤسس فاجناري
بريجوجن يدر الرماد على العيون
قبل دخول لتعلن قواته من مجموعة
فاغنر عبورها النهر الذي يقسم
باخموت الى قسمين وها هي تتجه
نحو مركز المدينة حيث قال
بريجوجن انهم على بعد الف ومئتي
كيلو متر من مبنى ادارة باخموت
بحسب اما نيوز. بينما تقول
القوات الموالية لروسيا ان الجيش
الاوكراني يقوم بنقل حوالي سبعين
الفا من قواته من محور زبروج الى
باخموت وفق وكالة نافوستي. فهل
بامكان الاوكراني استعادة ما
ابتلعه طباخ بوتين? بعيدا عن
باخموت. هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية
تفيد بصد اكثر من مائة هجوم روسي
في محاور متعددة خلال اربع
وعشرين ساعة. مضيفة ان البلاد
تعرضت لثلاثين غارة جوية ومائة
هجوم براجمات الصواريخ لتعلن
القوات الاوكرانية تنفيذ
طائراتها الحربية احدى عشرة غارة
على مواقع الجيش الروسي والحرب
تشتد اكثر فاكثر فالى اين
المصير؟ ليجيب المستشار السابق
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي العقيد
دوجلاس ماكفيجر بان الولايات
المتحدة افتعلت الازمة
الاوكرانية وكانت عاجزة منذ
البداية عن دعمها بالاسلحة
اللازمة لانتصارها. واضاف ان
مشكلة اوكرانيا هي طموحها في
محاربة خصم كبير نووية عالمية
مثل روسيا. المستشار لم يكن
وحيدا بهذا الرأي. اذ انضمت له
جلوبال تايمز مشيرة الى ان
الولايات المتحدة باستخدام
اوكرانيا وتسليحها والعقوبات
ارادت تدمير روسيا لكن رهان
واشنطن على كل ذلك كان خاسرا.
وهنا اعلنتها صحيفة لوفيكاغو
الفرنسية عن المؤرخ ايمانويل
تودز ان الغرب اشعل النزاع في
لكنه استخف بقوة روسيا والان
اصبح الناتو في خطر كبير. فعن اي
خطر يتحدث ومن معارك اوكرانيا
ينتقل الغرب الى التحضير لحرب قد
تكون عالمية هنا نحو عشرين الف
جندي من تسع دول بينها امريكا
وبريطانيا والمانيا وفرنسا الى
جانب خمسين طائرة واربعين سفينة
يشاركون في التدريبات الشتوية
الجارية في النرويج لتقول زوجة
الرئيس الاوكراني اوليناز
الينسكي اللغة الروسية بالنسبة
لنا هي لغة الحرب. وهنا الدفاع
النرويجية تنضم لقائمة اعداء
بوتين باعلانها تزويد اوكرانيا
بوحدتين كاملتين من منظومة
الدفاع الجوي ناسامز بالتعاون مع
الولايات المتحدة. بينما اعلن
مسؤول اوروبي ان الاتحاد ربما
يضخ ثلاثة مليارات ونصف المليار
يورو اضافية في الصندوق المستخدم
لشراء الاسلحة لاوكرانيا.
الاوكران بدورهم يحضرون لحرب
اخرى على ما يبدو. فحرس الحدود
من الاوكرانيين يحفرون خنادق على
الحدود مع مولدوفا بررت ذلك على
انه يهدف لمكافحة الهجرة غير
الشرعية والتهريب. فهل لي كذلك?
ام ان لهم مآرب الصين تتحدث بلغة
السلاح الامريكي. لا تغيير ولا
تبديل. النهج الصيني على خط
مستقيم فلا عودة الى الوراء ولا
توقف قبل نيل اصحاب العيون
الضيقة غايتهم. لتعيد بكين
انتخاب شي جين بينغ لولاية ثالثة
في رئاسة البلاد. وبلا اي مفاجآت
ودون اي منافس لصالح الزعيم
البالغ من تسعة وستين عاما. هنا
قال شي اتعهد بالعمل بجد لانجاز
مهامنا. مؤكدا انه لا يمكن للصين
ان تتطور من دون العالم والعالم
ايضا بحاجة الى الصين وفق
تعبيره. الرد الامريكي جاء
باختتام واشنطن اضخم تدريب عسكري
مشترك بالذخيرة الحية في
تايلاند. وهي من اطول التدريبات
العسكرية متعددة الاطراف في
لتعزز الولايات المتحدة
تحالفاتها في اسيا في وقت تزداد
المنافسة مع الصين. وهو ما حذرت
منه مجلة الامريكية في تقرير لها
من ان حربا وشيكة تقترب من
الاندلاع بين امريكا والصين بسبب
تايوان. واوضحت ان الشيء الوحيد
المؤكد هو انه حتى لو بقيت جميع
الاسلحة النووية في صوامعها فان
مثل هذا الصراع سيكون له عواقب
وخيمة ليس فقط بالنسبة لثلاثة
وعشرين مليون شخص في تايوان.
ولكن بالنسبة للعالم كله.
والعالم يحبس انفاسه يا سادة.
فهل تشتعل هذه الحرب. لكن بكين
تستعد لحرب امريكا بطريقتها
الخاصة. باستنساخ الاسلحة
الامريكية هنا وباقرار امريكي
سقطت فخر الجوية الامريكية اف
اثنان وعشرون عن عرشها في اقوى
جيش في العالم. لتستقر لدى اصحاب
العيون الضيقة حين سرقت بكين
تكنولوجيا هذه المقاتلة وضمتها
لقواتها بحسب فوكس نيوز. وماذا
بعد يا هؤلاء؟ الرياض وطهران
شوكة بظهر امريكا. ضربة بعد
اخرى. والعقبة تليها اختها
والاشواك تزداد على الطريق
الامريكي. لتوجه المملكة العربية
لكمتها القاضية نحو امريكا بعد
قرار اوبك بلس. وبعد سنوات من
القطاع الدبلوماسية بينهما اعلنت
السعودية وايران في بيان اشتركت
به الصين المستضيفة للوفود عن
وصل ما قطع واستئناف العلاقات
بين البلدين هنا قالت الخارجية
الصينية لا مصالح انانية لنا في
الشرق الاوسط. من جهتها تل ابيب
تحذر من هذا الاتفاق انه سيفتح
المجال لعلاقات اوسع بين ايران
ودول اقليمية كبرى بينها مصر.
الاحداث والتطورات. امريكا تعقد
اجتماعا في مجلس الامن يبحث
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في كوريا
الشمالية التي تهدد السلم والامن
الدوليين وتتعلق مباشرة باسلحة
الدمار الشامل وبرامج الصواريخ
الباليستية. ايمانويل ماكرون
يستقبل ريش في اول قمة بين
البلدين منذ الفين وثمانية عشر
وقضية الهجرة غير الشرعية كانت
محور اهتمامهما. المظاهرات
الحاشدة تتواصل في تل ابيب
مطالبة باقالة بن غفير هذه
المرة. وكان العملاق الصيني
والدب الروسي لا يكفيان. لتنضم
السعودية وايران كخصوم محتملين
للولايات المتحدة برأيكم. لما